dear my 20 year old self it's me well
you your idea of what is sexy will
change
drastically hey what about this girl she
sings together talk to that girl you're
going to make mistakes
they'll have names some of which you
can't remember but some of these names
will be etched into you for years also
you don't have to sleep with everyone
you'll miss the simplicity of holding
hands or the anticipation of the first
kiss you'll fall in love quickly with
the first person that shows you intimacy
you'll be happy for some of the time you
should tell her that you love her in
those moments you'll regret that you
didn't say it enough and the rest of the
time try not to spend it analyzing every
conversation ciphering text messages
like you're in the CIA trying to get
them to love you back if you think
someone is cheating they probably are
also nobody's ex's or best friend run
now when someone tells you they can't be
with you because they're going to ruin
you what they're actually saying is I'm
afraid you're going to ruin me so please
oh please walk away from this because I
don't know how to
it's okay to feel heartbroken you're not
damaged just because you're not
interested in a good person that's
interested in you how I mentioned you'll
make mistakes you don't need a million
reasons to end something you'll waste a
lot of time searching for those reasons
and above all else the most important
thing I can tell you is take care of
yourself first